so at 13 years old I had a had a kill
list
I got a hunt them down
now you got a problems right I don't
think I'm as I said this before
seriously seriously this is gonna be fun
Michael and particularly become my big
brother the greatest of all time but we
call them black Jesus you're not
intimidating me we're gonna go at it
it's crazy yeah man
you're about to take your shot and on
all of a sudden boom the kiss of death
you know my back was really spasming how
the hell do you tolerate that kind of
pain I play games with the flu I play
games with 102 degree fever man power
they all thought I was absolutely crazy
the day Mia shag on the fist fight spike
oh yeah that's why I'm not backing down
listen dude you got thrown me to Boston
man [ __ ] that getting off the rebound if
I miss broke you tell them this it
doesn't bother you I'm finding what the
hell do you want me to do got it
[Applause]
[Music]
here's to tonight's speaker is you ready
before I introduce him I want to tell
you what some of his accomplishments are
hey I got to tell you some of the things
he's done after the first one you're
gonna know who it is and if you jacked
up about it
I want you to holler and bring this
building down you ready let me say who
it is first first sentence ready you got
your lives on you ready
he is the greatest Laker of all time
five-time champion the only guard to
play with one team for 20 years
[Applause]
more 40-point games than LeBron and Kady
let me just say this guy's more 40-point
games than LeBron James and Kevin
Durant's more 50-point games more
50-point games than LeBron Kevin Durant
and Steph Curry combined and more 60
point games than LeBron James and
Michael Jordan combined give it up to
the one the only Kobe Bryant
[Music]
[Applause]
bear
all right now this is this is a company
this is the cop business to come
it's awesome wonderful so you know I
gotta tell you guys I gotta tell you
guys thank you thank you so we got to
try to get through this interview in 60
minutes so you know it's it's it's one
of the things a lot of you guys don't
know let me get your attention let me
get your attention settle down settle
you can stay where you are but just
settle down just don't make a lot of
noise so we can enjoy the interview I
get it little balance so you know one of
the things most you guys don't know we
were in the back Mario was asking me a
question
Mario asked me question he says what do
you think about when you think about
Kobe and I said the first thing that
comes to my mind is my dad he says why
your dad I said because you know he's
born August 23rd 78 yeah I'm October
1878 so you're sick then I have seven
weeks older than me so when he came to
the lake up in a die-hard Laker fan
since you know 1990 when I came to the
States from Iran and I never forget this
we would sit down watch the game
together my dad and I would watch you
play
and one day Lakers are playing against
76ers and it's Game one if you know my
dad you know he's a lot of heart attacks
we're watching Game one Iverson history
over uh right yeah game ends they
wouldn't get it first game my dad gets
up on my dad says Patrick take me to the
hospital we went straight to the
hospital because it was hard so that's
how much we go back grow up it was
amazing doing what you did for one
organization for twenty years but you
know before we get into it before we get
into it and kind of talk about what
you're working on today and some of the
mental toughness stuff here if I was in
high school with you if I was in high
school with you yeah outside of your
game mm-hmm outside you playing ball who
was Kobe Bryant as an individual and
personality in high school we were in
high school together much the same that
I am now actually which is extremely
curious
extremely curious I had a great teacher
in high school name is Jane Mastriano
well I'm still I'm still very close to
and she sparked my curiosity in writing
and the reason why I felt it was
important at the time was not for the
writing sake or not for storytelling
purposes but there are things in story
inherently in story that can help me be
a better basketball player be a better
teammate a better leader understand
emotions better so that's why I got into
it
it's a storytelling Ashley so it's just
insanely curious man and you know
trivial things weren't gonna pull my
attention it had to be sayings weren't
gonna pull my attention it had to be
things that were I had a purpose I want
it to be one of the best basketball
players to ever play and anything else
that was outside of that lane I didn't
have time for at what age did that goal
become crystal clear down there I made
that deal with myself at 13 years old at
13 years 13 years old I made clear about
it crystal clear and what did
inspiration come from the love of the
game the love of the game the challenge
like I would watch magic play I'd watch
Michael play and I would see them do
these unbelievable things and I'd say
you know can I get to that level
oh no but let's find out let's find out
and so that curiosity to see where I
could push this thing led me down that
path I think led you down that path I
think so now were you were you always
competitive from the day you were born
you were super competitive competitive
with things that I I participate in so I
like I'll put it to you this way slight
you know Michael is competitive in all
things things that don't make sense
right ain't pong yeah yeah you know you
know I'm saying so like he would try to
get me to play golf all the time Mike I
know about you I've written books report
about you and like elementary school
like I know you started playing golf
when you were in Carolina so that means
if I'm doing the math you've been
playing golf like a hundred years
I have not picked up a golf club ever
ever the last thing you're going to do
is give me on a golf course and
annihilate me not gonna do it you've
never picked up a golf no I did it one
time and I was hitting like 400 yard
grounders grounders and so it got my
competitiveness going like I gotta learn
this game but then I broke my finger
during that year and then I couldn't
play much and I was it so so the one
thing when I see with you and I think
about like brain and I think focus like
you know how so many different things
brain can get distracted on and I'm
gonna put focus on this and focus on
this and focus on this do you think one
of the edge you had over everybody else
was the biggest percentage of your focus
was on one thing listen do you see that
way like that was my edge over everybody
else I do at the time I didn't really
understand that right so you know
basketball for me was the most important
thing so everything I saw whether it was
TV shows whether it was books I read
people I talked to everything was done
to try to learn how to become a better
basketball player everything everything
and so when you have that point of view
then literally the world becomes your
library to help you to become better at
your craft the world becomes your
library to help you improve your craft
better your craft yes indeed so because
you know what she won the world's giving
you exactly the information 100-gram
better at it because you know what
you're looking for so would you when you
when you size your peers up how'd you
size your peers up like if your size and
people I'm talking you're 13 years old
your size and peers up what lens are you
looking through your peers so at 13
years old I had a I had a kill list and
so you know they used to do these
rankings who Street and Smith basketball
rankings and I was nowhere to be found
because I was like six four scrawny like
160 pounds soaking wet so I was like 57
on the list and so I will look at 56 55
all the way up to number one who these
players are with club teams they played
for so when we're going to a you travel
circuit I got to hunt them down
right and so that became my mission in
high school is to check off every other
person all those 56 other names hunt
them down and knock him down that was it
had a target on him right off the bat
that was it
very simple that's unbelievable let me
let me ask you this question you say say
I'm one of the guys on that list ahead
of you and we play what are you doing to
get a feel is it is your mind like are
you asking let me see if this guy's
better than me in this side and this
side and they said are you just going
saying I'm gonna kill this guy
well it depends what year so like in
that 13 years old I played the longer
game because my game wasn't about being
better than you at 13 it was it be
better than you when you know the chips
are really on on the line so we played
at 13 I was size you up and see what
your strengths and weaknesses are how do
you approach the game are you silly
about it are you goofy about it are you
good at it just because you're bigger
and stronger than everybody else right
or is there actually thought and skill
that you put into it right and when I
play I play to my weaknesses I wouldn't
play to my strengths I play to my
weaknesses because when you're playing
summer basketball there's so many games
so there's not a lot of skill work being
done so when are you gonna get better
right when you're playing in competition
situations you're only playing To Your
Strengths why because you want to win
right so what I would do I always work
on the things during those games that I
was weak at left hand pull-up jump shot
post game right so I have a strategy and
so then fast forward to when I'm 17 and
my game is completely well-rounded and
that player at 13 that I saw at 13 is
still doing the same [ __ ] at 17 now you
got a problems right got a problem and
you cut and you saw that you got a
problem and by the way let me ask you so
that's high school you're going to the
lead when you're going into the league
you're going with a lot of guys that
were you know same age same age you know
same classes you were going in yeah will
you sizing those guys at the same exact
way as you did in high school I did but
you know the NBA it was actually easier
because what I found that MBA is a lot
of guys played for financial stability
and when they came to the NBA they got
that financial stability
so therefore the passion and the
work ethic and the obsession the
obsessiveness was gone so I'm looking at
that I'm like oh my god it's gonna be
like taking candy from a baby that
wonder Mike wins all these [ __ ]
championships this is crazy
you know I'm saying like and then you
had the players that had that passion
but weren't willing to commit their
entire lives to doing that right it's a
choice you have other things your family
you have all these other things that you
have to do the game can't really be your
number one priority and so that's what's
looking at that like ma'am this is gonna
be fun and amuse and amuse you said I
knew you couldn't do what I was doing
because I was obsessed I'm paraphrasing
and then you said whether it's friends
relationship it didn't matter it was all
basketball yeah if the fun buddies with
you from high school if I'm a cousin of
yours what happened to our relationship
how did that gravitate when you went
into the league and you're you're
determined to become the greatest are
you determined to become one the
greatest what happens to our
relationship always suffers it does
stuff oh yeah okay yeah and you
understood that you were looking at well
yeah and the people that love you like
friends and family right they know that
about you
got it so they let you be you and when
you reconvene you know you pick back up
where you left off but make no mistake
about it everything in between is lost
right so those long-term relationships
the commitment of time of you know
taking Vega like I see a lot of players
take vacations with other players that
are close friends and I'll just take
vacations just to take vacations or just
hang out just to hang out like I'm not I
never did that
why so what why didn't you do that well
because when I retired I didn't want to
have to say I wish I would have done
more I don't want that
you know okay so okay so you come in
it's it's very powerful what you just
said some of your peers were in it for
the money so they got the money okay
great
buy a house for my mom dad wanted that
car get this get that have Fame go to
different cities I'm partying I'm doing
all this other stuff who are some of the
guys that you saw on your watch that
weren't just driven by the money where
there's some names that you looked at
and says these three guys or as crazy as
I am I do at the time I deal with what
I've referred to as goat mountain I went
to goat mountain and I talked to magic
Michael Bird Hakeem Olajuwon Jerry West
Oscar Robinson Bill Russell you know so
I would talk to them what did you do
what were your experiences Michael in
particular he's become my big brother
it's been my big brother since I first
came in the league and what was that
process like so I went to them I started
understanding the ins and outs of the
game and you know how they approach
things and their level of detail and
obsessiveness and that's what I did why
do you think first let me ask how it
felt but I'm curious to know why you
think as well how do you feel knowing
like from the moment you got into the
league the guy at the time he's the
greatest of all time everybody wants to
be like my Gatorade all this stuff the
level of respect he had for you when he
spoke about you was different than
everybody else and you're Nadine 19 year
old kid at that time yeah how did that
feel when you heard how we spoke about
you yeah it made me feel good but like
what I told him I was like you didn't
say anything I didn't already know so
you know so like wait I tell you like
when we when I was in high school and I
used to work out with the 76ers I used
to ask him you know what's it like the
guard Mike you know Mike mean black
Jesus like what though
black hoof but we call him black Jesus
or you can call him black cat I'm gonna
call him [ __ ] Mike that's his [ __ ]
name so the level of fear that he
inspired in others was insane and I
would tell him I said when I face him
we're gonna go at it this is odd you
don't want to do that I'm like what man
you don't know me man so when we matched
up I think he understood that and you
know when I was 18 my first year he got
the best of me a bunch of times
I was right there the next play you're
not intimidating me I'm not going
anywhere and I think you saw that level
of respect I think he was the same way
at 18 years old and that common bond is
what I think you know where our
connection was built yeah it was great
watching you guys going back and forth
whether it was the all-star game or
whether the famous scene where you know
you're guarding him he's in front of
you're asking him a question there's a
question and he same footwork and do
this yeah it's just beautiful watching
that take place with the two of you guys
how's your relationship today that was
my big brother man like I can't you know
it's uh we talk often you sent each
other's Christmas cards every year and
each other Christmas kever year that we
have nothing to do with but yet still
you know but we're extremely close man
extremely extremely close that's dream
that's great - yeah you know it's a as a
fan I'm not in your world your world is
a whole different world I just see it
from a fan and I just see it from what
experts say but as a fan I feel that's
exactly how would be with you and him
because the level of respect from both
is reciprocal and it's great to hear
that going a little bit past it you know
you came into the league you start
playing first year you get traded for
devack which we were devastated when we
lost Vlade Divac hard okay I think he
got the sarcasm some of you guys who
don't know basketball you missed out
like this but Kobe show I mean I'm like
a kid in a candy so when you show up
like oh no more sedale trees we can
nothing against these guys but we want
to entertainment you know yeah so you
show up and you play and there was the
one game I think you started getting a
little bit more playing time I think you
did seven point two points again because
they won't let you play the coach was
just not putting you in there yeah
second season was like 15 I I bet if you
take your first three and you played
ecology of twenty five point four would
probably would be a twenty six five
twenty six six top of a number yeah but
your first three seasons then the one
game it's the last game of the season
you play Utah yeah the one where you
shoot three air balls at the end I was
like five and then you hit one at ystem
doesn't go in right and Moses not Malone
one of the Malone's came and spoke to
you I don't know who was from the Jazz
well oh yeah say something you were not
even paying attention
Shaq was whispering something in your
ear what did Shaq say to you in that
moment I don't even know you don't
remember no I won't pay attention you
know like like it was you know like for
me it's maybe it's a little like [ __ ]
of me
whatever but whatever he was like he was
trying to whisper encouraging things I
was like I'm [ __ ] fine okay
I shot five air balls on national TV in
front of millions of people that cost us
the series and I'm 18 I'm fine dude how
do you get the meant how does somebody
get there mentally with that public
humiliation to some people Hurst them
and they don't come back because you
know there was a player Barbosa I don't
know if you remember aboard course
remember of course he was extremely
talented for a quick first step but they
said he wouldn't do well when the
spotlight was on him yeah did you get
mentally and emotionally so strong where
it doesn't bother you well you know it's
you got to look at the reality of the
situation you know like for me it's not
you know you kind of got to get over
yourself I think it's not about you man
like okay you feel embarrassed you're
not that important like get over
yourself yeah that's where you go get
over yourself
right like you're worried about how
people may perceive you and like you're
walking around and it's embarrassing
because you shot five air balls get over
yourself
right and then after that it's okay well
why did those air balls happen
got it high school year before we play
35 games
right week in between spaced out plenty
of time to rest in the NBA is back to
back to back to back to back to back to
back I didn't have the legs so you look
at the shot every shot was on line every
shot was on line but every shot was
short right I got to get stronger
I got a train differently the weight
training program that I'm doing I got a
tailor it for an 82-game season so that
when the playoffs come around my legs
are stronger and that ball gets there so
I look at it with rationale and say okay
well the reason why I shot airboats
because my legs aren't there I know I'll
make sure they'll be there that was it
done done and then what is your process
of improvement with your schedule
leaving because you know Phil Jackson
gets asked between you and MJ right
because he coach both of you guys so you
know you constantly gets asked that
question he's always gonna pick the
first child he's gonna pick the first
child but I tell you he said something
about you that to me it's a level of
respect that any player can duplicate
what he said about you to me the level
respect for that is a whole different
level
you can't teach big hands right right
you cannot right right you cannot teach
49 48 inch whatever the vertical leap is
and ya cannot teach that liar but he
said nobody in his history of coaching
had your level of work ethic I mean you
hear so many so many guys tell stories
about your work ethic yeah what was
really your work ethic like and for how
long did you stay disciplined well I
mean I mean every day I mean since 20
years it was an everyday process and
trying to figure out strengths and
weaknesses for example jumping ability
my vertical was a 40 it wasn't a 46 or
40 45 my hands are big but they're not
massive right so you got to figure out
ways to strengthen them so your hands
are strong enough to be able to palm a
ball and do the things that you needed
to do quickness I was quick we're not
insanely quick I was fast but not
ridiculously fast right so I had to rely
on skill a lot more I had to rely on
angles a lot more I had to study the
game a lot more and but I enjoyed it
though so like from the time I was I
came
remember when I started watching the
game I studied the game and it just
never changed technical question here
how you gonna answer this
who would Shaq be if he had your work
ethic he'd be the greatest of all time
if Shaq had you'll work they'd be the
greatest of all time by sure he he'd be
the first to tell you that for sure I
mean this guy was a force like I have
never seen I mean it was crazy you know
a guy that size generally guys at that
size or a little timid and they don't
want to be tall they don't want to be
big man this dude was he did not care he
was mean he was nasty he was competitive
he was vindictive I mean he was yeah I
wish he was in a John Wood had [ __ ]
12 rings he had the work ethic my god
yeah Wayne be close
Wow and let me ask you let me ask you
this question by the way I'm not asking
this question to create feud between you
and I am you you don't care sodomy I
mean Shaq talks it down all the time
when I say dude if your lazy ass in
shape
I hear you've seen all the time any all
right tell them all the time I'm asking
this question for a different reason I'm
asking this question because look we
we've grown as a company extremely fast
we went from one office with 66 agents
to ten thousand nine hundred offices
eight hundred eight and ten thousand
nine hundred agents in 49 states and
would have fastest growing insurance
company now but I say this I say it for
one reason and by the way this message
is directed to a lot of you so hear me
out
very simply the fanic that you say the
work ethic side your in fact they say
work ethic side and you say hey if you
would've worked that hard as I did
do you think if he would have had the
same level of commitment to the game as
you did you guys would have fewer feuds
between each other yeah because I listen
I don't I don't deal with people that
don't commit at that level but then act
as if they do I don't deal with that I
don't it's real [ __ ] I'm the other said
so like we we used to get into stuff all
the time because it was like you know
you would say okay Kobe's not throwing
me the ball and you know media would
take it and run with and also stuff and
I'm like well bro if you were in shape
by the time I run down on the fast break
and run back and then run down you're
still coming down the first time bro
like what the hell do you want me to do
right so a lot of our contention came
from that came from that and even though
he was older you were still fit
confronting him you didn't you didn't
kill I didn't care manly one bro from
day one I knew for sure Rick Fox my
teammates they all thought I was
absolutely crazy the day Mia Shaq got in
a fistfight
after that day they were like okay Kobe
you're certifiable
let's fight oh yeah I'm not backing down
listen either you want to whip my ass or
I'm we want to have a knife but
you know hey no way you know there's a
there's a level of respect and for Shaq
to by the way now I know he's told me
that that day was a big turning point
for him because it was like you know
he's generally used to talking trash and
saying what he wants and nobody really
stepping up and challenging him on that
and when he saw me challenge him on that
he was like this kids crazy alright I
can win with that you know and so that
was kind of the beginning of our
relationship I think that's probably
never happened to him that's probably
not something that's common to him no
it's awesome salsa Terry years old or
something right it was all this is all
coming back to me right now this is also
a game in Phoenix my first year we were
playing
he kept posting up but they can't found
him so he kept going to freeze a lot of
kept missing him and so he throw the
ball out to me I'm not throwing that
[ __ ] back in there oh I kept shooting
him right so we get the timeout he's
like hey uh hey I'm open like okay so if
we go out and same thing coming hey I'm
open okay okay come again
hey dude you gotta throw me to Boston
man [ __ ] that get it off the rebound if
I miss bro you told them this first
you're 18 years old man 18 years old I
must have been out of my damn mind so
did you have guys you went to outside of
the players like when you come in to
figure out a way to improve your your
game we had Billy Beane here a couple
days ago and I don't know if you know
Billy Beane is if you seen a movie
Moneyball he's worse Billy be horse so
he talked a lot about predictive
analytics he talked about the fact that
the year Moneyball came out that your
prior to that they paid players and
looked at on-base percentage as eight
stats and the your Moneyball came out
all the scouts started making on base
percentage number one was a recruit aful
right did you have ways to improve your
game by looking at data looking at
conditioning what were some of the
factors you looked at on how to improve
your game season after season
the game itself was it's a it's a
complicated answer so there there are
very tactical things in terms of
footwork and geometry of the court so
you're looking at the court and looking
at the 45-degree angle is that the court
is is shaped in and how it needs to
operate that's one component to it so
looking at spots on the floor where you
can increase your efficiency right you
can be on the wing but there's a certain
spot on the wing that improves your
angle to drive to the basket right so
that's sort of stuff footwork of the
opposition looking at the emotion of the
opposition their tendencies their
weaknesses and all that stuff
understanding the momentum of the game
how to create momentum shifts where
momentum ships come from all this sort
of stuff and then studying outside of
that right looking at different
industries looking at conductors looking
at riders looking at actors and how they
get into character and then how they
keep themselves in that mental space so
looking at different different
industries looking at nature itself
learning from that and how you can
incorporate that into the game man it's
it was a lot of studying what's your
process for making a decision do you
have a flow of how you go through making
a decision depends on the decision
depends on the decision if we're talking
about you know a basketball decision
we're read a certain coverage or
something like that and a lot of that
comes from the the pre-work pre-work and
understanding what their defensive
packages and how to put teammates in
certain situations so for example if you
look at players nowadays that are
charged with taking game-winning shots
or making game-winning decisions and you
look at the play and then you look and
say okay well that shooter was there the
double-team came and you know the player
can do anything but pass the ball right
well that's because they didn't do the
pre-work right so we do the pre-work you
understand okay this team in a situation
likes to run a double-team from this
particular angle all right so I'm gonna
clear that side out force the
double-team to come from a different
angle move myself to a space on the
floor where it's gonna take a long time
for the double-team to come and now I
can circumvent the double-team and get
to a place on the floor where I can
knock down a shot to get to the basket
so it's it's all
pre-work the decision when I say
decision how was a if you're looking at
somebody that you were sizing up or if
you're looking at somebody to go into
business with if you're looking at a big
investments you got to make what is the
decision making process there do you
call is their first you do your own
research you take this much time you
call an advisor reserve is there a
system you know it's pretty pretty
simple for me if it sits do you
understand the business is it a business
that you can help in some form of
fashion whether the barriers entry to
that business and then the entrepreneurs
themselves the company that itself do
they have a culture that you believe is
sustainable are these leaders people
that you believe in are they people that
are obsessive and in turn have they
created a culture of obsessiveness so I
tend to look at those four factors and
that's it that's that's big right there
by the way I don't know if you guys
caught that right there that's pretty
massive right there earlier you said I'm
probably not gonna get this right a 16
year old a 13 or 11 year old yeah 13 16
13 2 & 1 that's a month 1 that's a month
by the way right one that's a month all
girls all girls 4 4 4 so 16 means you're
in your fifth sixth year 60 or having a
baby yes it's something like that right
give or take what was the conversation
like with your wife to say listen this
is the schedule because look you know
some entrepreneurs they're coming home
at night and late oh my gosh my wife is
upset because I came home at 7:30 oh my
goodness what a sacrifice I'm making you
know this wipes you know I don't know if
I can do this
sure you're on the road nine months out
of the year if you play Doland you want
to gold medal so you're doing that on
the off season are you trying to get
that part going and training for doing
your camps what is the conversation life
would like with your wife and kids to
say listen this is what I'm doing how
did that conversation go well what the
kids is different so like the
communication would be with our children
is a
Pop's is working hard this is the level
of attention to detail you need to have
in everything you do
so it's it's setting the example same
thing with my wife my wife's a
stay-at-home wife it's the hardest job
man so she works really hard at that I
mean it's you know and so her attention
to detail with that as well or examples
for our children and then for my wife
it's you know she's as competitive as I
am she's just like listen man if you're
gonna be out here training
eight hours a day if you're gonna spend
nine months out of year away from the
family you better [ __ ] win the
championship go ahead okay what are we
doing this for what are we doing up what
are we doing love that you know but it's
a balancing act and that's the thing
that's important is understanding that
we have to have so much energy because
for like Natalia and Gianna when they
were babies especially not Thalia
because it was doing prime years and I
go to practice and I train and play the
game and I come home and I'd be sore and
I'd be tired and she wants to go
swimming and she wants me to take her to
the park she wants to just jump on my
back or whatever the case may be you
can't say I'm too tired I'm going to lay
down mmm that's not fair she doesn't
know what the hell is going on right and
if this was a game you'd suck it up and
play I play games with the flu I play
games with 102 degree fever man I can't
do that hey all-powerful you gotta be on
man that's they that you guys would you
would you sit at the because you you're
obviously very detailed your show I mean
you're very very detailed guide would
you guys have a meeting like I sit in
it's okay if I'm cold I'm thinking like
Kobe let's just say Kobe's trying to
schedule out his your season is about to
start would you sit with her and say
okay babe this is the schedule next 12
months
tell me about birthdays tell me about
this yeah is that is that what you guys
do yeah I look at it and say okay
birthdays what am I missing
Valentine's Day Halloween Christmas you
know Easter like all that fun stuff
I look at the schedule and see what I'm
there for what I'm not there for
Christmas is in a road game or a home
game this year and then we make a family
decision family travel do I come back
like sometimes I fly back like I'd play
a game and to not miss my daughter's
birthday I'd fly back be there for a
birthday and then fly back with the team
yeah just to make sure I don't miss
anything
respect what's the least amount of sleep
you played a game on no there's story
where it's like you know no one knows
about what you went and played a game
and it was so insane for whatever
reasons no sleep you played a game games
really seriously it's like you know kids
Mitali I had a certain you know health
situation what have you and you staying
up all night and then you got to go out
and perform because fans don't know
teammates don't know nor do they care
nor should they that you've been up all
night you got to perform right and so
you just got it's got to go to work
man's respect that's respect and and I
think one of the things for some if you
follow basketball or not that you and
Mike had in common is that it wasn't say
I'm gonna take eight games off this year
to try to stay healthy you know like
that to you as comic I like to do that
the hell is that and I don't know that
it is this crazy seriously it's crazy
like you know you got a lot of people
playing their hard earned money to come
watch you perform perform before sure a
job to be in shape it's your job to be
strong enough to perform at that level
every single night and as a competitor
I'm not I'm not ducking [ __ ] like it's
not oh my god I'm my back hurts I'm sore
we got to play Vince Carter and Toronto
Raptors tonight we actually had this
happening we had a game against Toronto
and 2000 and Vince was tearing the
league oh my back was jacked
jacked but like the perception of that
like blood Kobe's missing the game
against Toronto
Vince Carter because my back was really
spasming but people will be like what
oh he's ducking Vince excuse me
no I don't think so so I would be in the
layup line like okay there's a lot of
days where you know you can rest and
recover today ain't one of them
your back can bother you any other day
that [ __ ] even bothering me today we
gonna he gonna have to see me today yeah
oh man yeah he was another one that came
in you thought for sure you know he was
gonna be where the and a whole different
league when he came and obviously he
just extract know what his vertical leap
was 46 47 out of this war or what he
does best dunker I've ever seen insanity
I mean insanity is why they call him
that so crazy you're an alpha you have a
very strong personality extremely strong
personality and then you got a team with
Shaq and then you got a team with Phil
Jackson and you guys are all working
together how was it taking coaching from
an alpha in urine alpha and was there a
progression of you finally understanding
him or him understanding and what did
that look like the relation between you
and Phil no at first it was rocky but I
didn't understand it was rocky and let
me elaborate
I was extremely naive and with Phil and
his genius his responsibility was to get
the team to a place to win titles it
wasn't a piece to appease one player it
wasn't to look out for this player it
was to get the collective whole to win a
championship so he would do whatever it
took to make sure that that happened hmm
he would see the friction between myself
and Shaquille and say okay how can I use
that alright
I know Kobe has a passion of play so
come hell or high water doesn't matter
what's going on in his personal life
doesn't matter what's happening here
with the team he's gonna show up and
perform no matter what Shaq is more
emotional if something's going on he
won't so therefore I got to figure out
how to create a wedge between myself and
Cole because then that brings me closer
to Shaquille and then that helps me
better man in Shaq so that was his
ability to manage the team which was
absolutely brilliant I should tell him
all the time I said Phil look I know
what you're doing bro like don't insult
my intelligence I know you're being a
dick to me on purpose like just like
tell me no no okay you don't stick stay
with
all right cool all right how's your
relationship tilted em you guys want
fights like a father-figure
really yeah it feels like a
father-figure man so when you were
hearing all the experts saying what
there was in comment there saying what
they were saying about Phil how were you
taking that when they were saying what
they were saying about him with when he
was at the Knicks I thought it was funny
I thought it was funny I told Phil said
Phil I know this is all just Karma
for writing literally three books about
me this is your karma I did tell this is
all in good fun but I was upset because
people don't understand him and he is a
genius and every sense of the word and
how he sees the game how he sees the
spirituality of the game and people
don't understand that and worse than
that they're intimidated by that and
even worse they try to discredit that
because they do not have the level of
passion and obsessiveness obsessiveness
to get to that level so they figure the
best thing to do is to tear that level
down that's [ __ ] up I'm with you there
are harder percent by the way
[Music]
obviously had a lot of interesting
rituals you would hear about the yoga
you would hear about all the stuff that
we do he would do but it's a weirdest
thing he did with you in practice that
you're like what the hell are we doing
here yeah he had a Tai Chi master come
to practice and we walk out there and
you know the Tai Chi master standing
center court and tells us to take our
shoes off take our shoes off and I'm
pissed because I'm I'm ready to like
play basketball he's standing up there
and says everybody closes your eyes and
stuff and he does stuff like monk gazing
at moon and talks about the fingertips
and barely touching in the spirituality
of all that and I'm peeking around like
he's everybody doing it [ __ ] like going
on and there you know big-ass Phil
Phil's there doing it himself he's like
you know he's doing this whole like
doing all this stuff you know I'm like
damn okay I'm gonna try it but honestly
it it I bought into it I bought into the
meditation I bought into the deeper
connection that exists within the game
and so when you watch our teams or you
watch any of Phil's teams or Chicago
teams game 6 against Utah you watch our
games you know Game seven against Boston
we were never rattled ever because we're
always in the moment always in the
present always extremely calm always
looking at the reality of the situation
and not letting our emotions cloud our
execution and that comes from being a
meditative state that you would teach
and preach from day one what would he
take you back would he take you back
would he take you back and say you had a
terrible game and it was you know the
season prior would he take you back and
say we're gonna watch this game it was a
worst loss we had it was absolutely
embarrassing for you to kind of see what
things you did to him for was he that
kind of was he know it was more about
fundamentals and improving the game one
he was very hands-off in the sense of if
you allow players to develop
who allow you to find your truth and
then go after it he was there to simply
guide you along that journey which I
actually learned from him and that's how
I parent and that's how I coach my
daughter's team now so that's why I say
he's a father figure because I've
learned so much from him as a coach that
I take as a father as a husband and as a
coach myself but he was very he's very
observant
was he a one on better one on one or one
on few like one on one versus one at 12
okay if I'm having a team meeting and
I'm talking to guys to rally them or
calm him down or it's okay strategy
where is he very good one-on-one just
you and him closed doors yes
great conversationalist but hated
confrontation he hated comfort direct
confrontation is not his thing doesn't
do it never did well with it had a lot
to do with how he grew up in his you
know his brother his siblings and father
and so forth I saw hates direct
confrontation and he knew that about
himself so that's why a lot of his
challenges were indirect he went to the
media with things so he's very indirect
he would never challenge a player
directly didn't like that yeah he said
one time you guys had a meeting and he
set you down a shack done and says
listen I know you guys think you're
alpha I'm a bigger alpha into both of
you guys did that ever take place was
not really not no it was more like you
know he would say it in film sessions
not with me and shag like he never sat
me and shag down like him me and shag he
never told god no you kidding why
wouldn't you those at the concert a I'm
sure it'd be a little terrifying for got
it it mad at me Phil you never seen Phil
walk I mean Phil you know he's got like
one good hip one like the best day of
his life it's like if some [ __ ] goes
down he is doing nothing to break that
up so I'm so much a little intimidating
but what he would do is he would do
things indirect and it wasn't about
calming the waters it was about stirring
up the waters and creating a storm
that eventually will lead this broken
ship to the shore it was trying to get
to in the first place with you
constantly instigating and steering
kanessa way that's what he was doing it
so like if you ever seen the movie Moana
if anybody has kids here I'm sure you've
seen Juan oh right
when she goes out and all of a sudden
there's a storm and she loses her mind
thinks everything is lost and all of a
sudden she wakes up and she's right
where she was supposed to be that's fit
that's a great example that a great
example so we're coming down to the last
15 minutes I got a list of questions
that I'm not gonna get to but I do want
to ask a couple these is you're playing
against the Golden State Warriors score
is 107 109 you guys are close to getting
into the playoffs you know exactly what
happens in the game you go up you're
about to take your shot and then all of
a sudden boom you're Healy's happens
right friend of mine Nima he is here
just to listen to he played ball and he
told me sis Patrick I don't think you
understand he says when I told my
achilles in high school there's four
friends of mine dragged I was crying
from there straight to the hospice it's
I have no clue how the hell this guy did
it he went and hit the free throws and
then you walked off the stage yeah you
got the surgery back yeah
how the hell do you tolerate that kind
of pain you know I tell this example and
I think this is the best way to explain
it you know you have a hamstring injury
you pull your hamstring really really
badly you can barely walk right let
alone play anything soccer basketball
volleyball whatever it is can't do
anything doctor tells you go home sit up
on the couch rest your hammie right stay
off of it
don't get up no sudden movements you're
at home all of a sudden of a fire breaks
out in the home right your kids are
upstairs
[Music]
you know wife is wherever she may be you
know as shits going down all right I'm
willing to bet that you're gonna forget
about your hamstring
you're gonna sprint upstairs you're
gonna grab your kids you'll make sure
your wife's good you're getting out of
that house right hamstring be damned
you're not gonna fill your hamstring
right and the reason is because the
lives of your family are more important
than the injury of your hamstring and so
when the game is more important than the
injury itself you don't feel that
damaged not at that time so you go to
the locker room you guys had a shot that
you know to go into the play you guys
were a team that no one wanted to face
even though there was conflict you know
maybe if you would have gone round one
who knows maybe the white would have
gone together he knows who knows what
what's gonna happen you were the kind of
team that look it's just a painting
about to face these guys I was hoping
you don't make the playoffs right I'm
sure a lot of people were very happy
that you guys didn't make the playoffs a
year but you go into the locker room and
then one of the reporters comes up to
you and he says to you Kobe are you
convinced that they told you it's
probably torn Achilles they're gonna do
an MRI are you pretty convinced that's
what it is and your ass and answer is
yeah then one of the reporters says but
if anyone is gonna get through this it's
probably you right you put your head
down and you say oh man [ __ ] right in
your tears in your eyes yeah did you say
all man [ __ ] because everybody's
expecting me to be invincible man like
freaking let me just play the fan game
I'm a human being is that kind of what
you were thinking or so like the world's
expect me to come back in the next month
cause I'm Kobe like what were you
thinking about all that pressure I was
thinking like I don't know if I can do
this the kilise were like the kiss of
death
yeah athletes like yes I don't I don't
know if I can do this I don't know
there's so many factors is the surgery
that has to take place the surgery has
to go well right and then just it's a
tendon I'm not dealing with anything
that's muscular things that I can
control I can't control a tendon you
know and so I like
No and then thinking about what that
process of recovery is going to look
like it's a long one do I want to do
that [ __ ] I don't I don't know if I only
do it
I don't know so that was the hardest
part you don't know if you want to do it
or you don't know if you are gonna be
able to come back from it both like oh
no if I can do it I don't know if I want
to do without it miss it's a long
process but like when I win the
trainer's room my kids are in there and
you know they're looking at you and
stuff and I'm looking at them and I'm
like you know sorry
dad's gonna be all right would be fine
it'll be alright it'll be alright it'll
be alright as a parent you gotta set the
example you gotta set the example this
this is another obstacle this obstacle
cannot define me it's not going to
[ __ ] me it's not going to be
responsible for me stepping away for the
game that I love I'm gonna step away on
my own terms and that's when the
decision was made that you know what I'm
doing it doing it
I noticed a lot of times you go and you
talk about like the even the example use
right now if your hamstrings are this
your down your wife's upstairs your kids
your going to think of my gun or so did
you have a lot of these sinners you will
you use your wife and your kids to use
as no excuse I'm gonna get through this
was that a mental conversation you had
that nobody could hear yeah you got to
lead by example
there's parents you got to leave by
example if you want your kids to do
whatever it is they want to accomplish
in life you have to show them hmm you
can't you got to show them that's what I
tried to do and you're obviously doing
that man at a whole different level at
alter ego let's do alter ego in and I
want to kind of go into the story side
and how you went into the story telling
that you wanna get it guys this guy won
an Academy Award he's a basket how the
hell does that make any sense right
there's a frickin Academy Award right so
alter ego alter ego you know sometimes
we are so worried about what other
people think about us you know it's like
oh my gosh what if they think I'm crazy
what if they think I'm over obsessive or
competitive and what if this is like
you're too much this is just not healthy
for you to be thinking this way right
yeah how did you get your mindset into
this alter ego to be comfortable being
black mama look how did that happen it's
a good separation for me you know
emotionally to be able to put myself in
a place where at practice or when I'm
training or during games I switched my
mind to something else I switched my
mode into something else right for me
it's the equivalent of Maximus Decimus
Meridius and gladiator picking up the
dirt smelling dirt is go Tom right so
that was my mental switch it was like an
actor getting ready for a film you got
to put yourself in that cage when you're
in that cage you are that character and
then when you leave there is something
completely different when I'm in that
cage bro don't [ __ ] touch me don't
talk to me
leave me alone I used to be certain
games like for like certain key games I
don't think I'm as I said this before
this kind of makes me seem very
psychotic but whatever I used to play
the Halloween theme song over and over
and over in my headphones pregame
seriously seriously seriously and it was
important that it was Michael Myers
because the mask itself was the void of
emotion void of emotion sure it has
nothing to do with hype has nothing to
do with camaraderie stone-cold killer
and I would listen to that song over and
over and over again that's that's when
you know you better run because that's
what a lot of people that this probably
coming out of you know my story yeah so
told me you've probably made in this 50
minute conversation I don't know 12
metaphors so typically people that make
metaphors they're storytellers to them
everything has to paint a picture and
from the day one you're talking on you
were very curious right so when you
finish the last game you had and I'll
never forget we were having a training
by the way in Dallas and we finished it
this was three years ago and my sister
and I get home it's 12:30 I was hoping I
could catch the game it's your last game
you playing you Tom
yeah and I'm stand-up the entire time
I'm getting the last four minutes which
is the best freaking four minutes and I
see your shacks and go for 50 and then
you you're just going and you're not
heading easy shots these are not easy
shots you hit your last shot you scored
sick guys nobody has ever had a 60 point
game to retire with or happen like it's
insane for this to happen
you hit your 60 points I gotta say this
my sisters in the room Kolby I got tears
coming down now watching you when this
happens because 20 years I've been
following this guy and I relate to you
because in the insurance world I take a
lot of your similarity you may be in a
complete different world I'm looking at
the world here and it's just like seeing
this guy he's so freakin determined to
say I came and gave everything I had and
I'm gonna give it to the last
frickin second that's what you did but
then you leave and you're like no it's
good I'm cool you tell your story you
give your message everybody's flipping
out you're like now Kobe's gonna come
back now go Vinny you're going are you
going to your story telling all this
stuff how did that disconnect and going
into that going you're still helping out
a lot of players
you're always advising Laker you know
Jeannie calls you anybody calls you're
helping out no problem but how did that
just me go from there to all of a sudden
now I got to go tell stories yeah did
that happen because I love it so you
know started for me again in high school
when I started learning about
storytelling writing how to structure a
story how to put together how to thread
together a narrative that has a bigger
message how to create compelling
characters how to take some of the
emotions from not from my own journey
and instill them into characters that
inspire or teach the next generation
therefore they can avoid some of the
pitfalls and landmines that I had to go
through
that's something I'm extremely
passionate about so I loved it so it
wasn't a matter of May I got you know I
got to put this aside I got move on to
something else I was excited and I can't
wait to get started I can't wait to move
on and do something else and everybody
kept saying man like it my wife asked me
one time we were filling out a form for
school and it said father occupation
she's like what am i what am I supposed
to put down you know I want storyteller
you want me to write storyteller or your
kids form Wow yeah I guess I mean that's
what I'm doing because dude really
artifice producer I don't know
right but during that year everybody
kept coming up to me and saying okay
you're gonna have stages of grief when
you retire are you're gonna go into a
state of depression when you retire and
those are all normal and also their
stuff and I'm like dude I'm fine yes of
course you would say that I said that to
my two
[ __ ] man and so I have to a while just
start listening like oh yeah yeah you
know and then my competitive
competitiveness inside was like no I'm
gonna do something in the next 20 years
that is better than these last 20 you
might not understand that I'm doing that
you know you know so the competitiveness
kicks in you gone same determination
what's your current work schedule look
like today it's it's uh it's different
because I personally am NOT writing
every word of the novels I am not
animating the films what I have to do
now is make sure that the people that we
bring in these obsessives that we bring
in are challenging themselves to do the
best job that they think they can do
that's what I'm there for is for them to
constantly look in the mirror and self
assess and challenge themselves if we
have a project and you're saying okay I
can do that that's not the project we
want the projects that say I don't know
if I can animate that I don't know how
to write that story I don't know how to
do that those are the things we want
because through that curiosity you'll
reach a level that you didn't think was
possible and so running the studio
that's what I'm doing
[Applause]
are you a you a big movie guy your views
okay so how do you watch movies like you
know my experience that people watch
movies in many different ways not
everybody watches movies the same way
when you're watching movies
how are you watching a movie I watch him
multiple times and I wear different hats
every time so the first time I watch it
I watch it just as a fan for pure
entertainment value then I watch it from
the directors lens and see why he made
some of the scissors or she made some of
the decisions that she made for the film
and then I look at the lighting lighting
oh yeah light and assuring the important
course oh yeah that now listen to the
music and then you can challenge
yourself by really understanding the
directors point of view if you watch a
film without music and without sound
then you can actually see the film for
what it is so I'll watch it at different
different stages I mean obviously
Academy Awards that you won the
gentlemen you hired for the sound was in
a jump is it John William John will do
the right and John Williams is like the
goat in his world oh you know a
modern-day Beethoven yeah this guy I
mean this guy's compose any song right
now that you can remember from a film
he's done Superman theme did that
Indiana Jones did that Jaws did that
Harry Potter did that the Olympics theme
did that - I mean the list goes on and
on and on and on and you know he's like
85 years old that's crazy
yeah man doing the new Star Wars film
now Oh Star Wars - that part you did
that one - yeah so when you say
recruiting and putting a team together
with your projects today who are you
recruiting like you know if you're
putting a basketball team together Union
GM president you know trainers all this
stuff assistant good coach what do you
need right now when you put it for
example right now building out an
animation house right so you got to
start with the head of the snake yeah
look at the person that's better
understands the type of animation that
you want to create and they have to be
obsessives have to have a knowledge base
the historical knowledge base because I
love people that understand the
history of their industry ends an ounce
of it all and then you you bring that
person into the picture and then you
allow them to do what you brought them
in to do so you leave them alone kind of
like Phil left you guys alone - I'm not
gonna hire you to tell you how to do
your job
got it so recruiting well obviously in
the league you were known as a great
recruiter so what is your recruiting
approach so if you're sitting down with
me I'm somebody you really want you
really want me on the team
what's your approach to recruit me you
want first place come play with me you
want a second place go somewhere else
it's too much fun here final thoughts
man what are we going to see with Kobe
next 20 years what other projects got in
mind that you're working on right now
the biggest challenge for us is looking
at the entertainment industry and how to
diversify it particularly in animation
but also in writing and and and young
wai' a novels middle grade novels how to
create more diverse characters how do we
have better representation how do we
create better opportunities not just an
ethnicity but also gender diversity I
have four girls right so my mission is
to make sure women have opportunities
that they are haven't been afforded that
is my made I'm the father of four girls
so that is my next obsession is how do
we lead that charge from the front how
do we take an animation industry that
lacks in diversity substantially lacks
in diversity
how do we take some of those old
animation techniques and teach a whole
new generation of animators to come in
and create films to inspire the world
and we're getting after it I think
everybody knows crystal clear Kobe is
gonna get whatever Kobe wants man
brother appreciate you for coming out
and truly this has been a blast maybe
some noise Kobe Bryant thank you
I got a gift for you my doll I gave him
the gift thank God let me give you this
gift
alright let me give you this gift you
have it so first one I'm gonna give you
is this this is something that you
represent and we have to go get your
size and it's just saying that post-game
you are now an entrepreneur so we're
giving you shirts this right that's your
word and next one word you said script
so we went and got a Star Wars for the
hawaikan script signed by JJ Abrams man
space oh that's amazing
I hope roll wait thank you I hope you
enjoyed thank you thank you thank
thankful coming on then thank you no
thank you for coming out thank nabob
thank everybody make those Kobe Bryant
well
[Music]
[Applause]